is the big day Marvel's Hall H panel at
San Diego comic-con how's it going
everybody it's Warren and today we
finally get to hear from Marvel about
the future of the MCU and see the phase
for slate just so everybody is aware
Marvel Studios is Hall age presentation
is today and it will start at 5:15 and
end at 6:45 and that is Pacific Standard
Time so if you're on the Eastern
Standard Time that is going to be 8:15
to 9:45 and if you are on BST that is
going to be 1:15 a.m. to 2:45 a.m. and
as soon as it's revealed I will be doing
a video on it so be sure to come back to
my channel later on today but last night
in the Avengers endgame Hall H panel we
got some major reveals for the movie so
I will report everything that was
revealed in this video quick heads up
the winners for the 450,000 subscriber
giveaway have been chosen I did a video
announcing them last night be sure to
check that out but now my 500,000
subscriber giveaway starts still giving
away Marvel Legends items but also
giving away a xbox one or a ps4 the
winner gets to choose same rules for the
giveaway still apply must be subscribed
to my channel like the video and comment
down below with your favorite superhero
or villain I'm also giving away an
Infinity Gauntlet on Instagram so if
you'd like a chance to win that you can
follow me on there cosmic war in 13 so
the first big reveal last night from
Christopher Markus and Stephen McFeely
was that there was a scene that was
supposed to be an Avengers in game where
Thanos actually decapitates cuts off
Captain America's head now it wasn't the
present Captain America it was the 2012
Captain America that we saw an Avengers
in game according to the writers the
past version of Stannis would have gone
back in time to 2012 and killed every
single Avenger and then he would have
taken Captain America's head back to the
present time to taunt the current
Avengers this would have been an insane
scene to see and ultimately they said
they left it out because they didn't
want to traumatize children but I think
Fano is coming back to the present time
with Captain America's head in his hand
would have traumatized pretty much
anybody ultimately it might have been a
pretty cool scene to see because it's
not the real Avengers that are dying in
the present time but that would have
created a huge different branch reality
the next thing that we discovered is
actually a really big confirmation a lot
of fans have
wondering about Gomorrah at the end of
Avengers endgame she was technically
part of fan OSes army and we know that
star-lord was searching for her but
couldn't find her at the end of the
movie so many fans have wondered when
iron man snapped was Gamora snapped away
because she was technically part of
Thanos army but luckily for us the
writers answered this question last
night and they said yes she is still
alive she probably just went on the run
so it looks like we're probably going to
see the rest of her story play out in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 another
thing that the ride was revealed is that
we almost saw professor Hulk or Smart
Hulk as Marvel likes to call him appear
in Avengers infinity war the writer said
that the original idea was for professor
Hulk to pop out during his battle with
Coll obsidian ultimately they left it
out and decided that it didn't really
fit right and decided to introduce him
in Avengers endgame another big reveal
from the writers is that originally when
Thor rocket and Groot went to net of
lair to get Stormbreaker Thor would have
had to originally fight a giant Midgard
serpent the writer said that originally
Thor would have had to battle this
serpent in order to obtain the ax
however stephen mcfeely said that they
decided to leave this scene out because
and i quote him here it sucked
i think that it would have actually been
a pretty cool scene to see but I'm
definitely happy with how his story
played out in Avengers infinity war and
the last major reveal that we learned
from the writers is that the Living
Tribunal was originally supposed to be
in the end of Avengers in game during
the final battle originally Doctor
Strange and fan OHS in the final battle
of Avengers in game were supposed to
have a rematch a rematch in which Doctor
Strange would have sent Thanos his mind
into the mindscape presenting him with
all his various crimes before having him
judged guilty by the Living Tribunal
this would have been an insane scene to
see now the Living Tribunal was
mentioned in Doctor Strange so this
actually does make perfect sense that
Doctor Strange would know how to send
Thanos to the Living Tribunal to be
judged it would have been really cool to
see a cosmic entity enter Avengers in
game but ultimately I think everybody is
really happy with Iron Man snap but
those are all the major reveals and
deleted scenes that we learned last
night from the writers of Avengers
endgame be sure to let me know what you
think about this and be sure to head
back to my channel tonight to hear all
about the phase 4 lineup and the future
of the MCU be sure to comment down below
with your thoughts and also your
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel to enter my
giveaway and also you can follow me on
Instagram if you'd like a chance to win
an Infinity Gauntlet as well as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof